loss we are also stepping up our work on
environmental justice
communities of color low-income
communities
and tribal communities often suffer the
most harm
from environmental crimes and pollution
among our efforts we are seeking
increased resources for our environment
natural resource division
to help these vulnerable populations
the antitrust laws are the charter of
our economic liberty
and the justice department is committed
to enforcing them
the fy 22 request for increased
resources for the united trust division
reflects that finally
there are nearly 1.3 million cases
pending before the immigration courts
a 21 budget increase for the executive
office for immigration review
will help support 100 new immigration
judges
improve technology and other efficiency
mechanisms
to reduce that backlog
i have mentioned only a few of the
department's important programs this
morning
i ask your support for our budget as the
entire department
works to ensure adherence to the rule of
law
protection of public safety and equal
justice for all americans
thank you very much
thank you attorney general garland uh at
this time
we'll start the questioning period i'll
open by recognizing myself for five
minutes of questioning
um i want to start with civil rights and
in particular
voting rights uh i'm
i'm 60 years old attorney general
garland and and for
almost my entire life what was normal in
the united states
was that if a jurisdiction wanted to
change its voting laws it had to get
pre-clearance from the justice
department
and or the uh the district court in the
district
of columbia that was because of the
voting rights act of 1965.
now the voting rights act of 1965 came
about
largely because of the efforts of our
dear departed colleague john lewis
and his efforts that culminated in a
bloody sunday
in selma alabama in the spring of 1965
and it led to the passage of that bill
uh and into law in in august uh that was
sustained by the united states supreme
court
uh in south carolina versus katzenbach
the next year
uh and it has been called one of the
most
effective pieces of civil rights
legislation in american history um
in fact that was called that by by the
justice department in 2014.
all of that was upended in 2013
by the shelby county decision which all
of a sudden
invalidated the pre-clearance
requirement so now
uh instead of normal what we have is the
justice department has to file
suit every time uh there's a
an unconstitutional change in voting
laws
that are that offends the 15th amendment
or some other part of the constitution
and as a result your justice department
uh has to spend a lot more money filing
lawsuits to to uh to uh
to reverse these voting law changes am i
correct in that
you're muted sir
i'm sorry we'll try to get the
technology better um this is my first
virtual hearing
um yes you are you are correct uh shelby
county
invalidated the coverage formula which
permitted the pre-clearance
program to continue uh so it is now the
case
uh that the justice department is
largely limited
uh to bringing affirmative cases in
which it finds under section two
of the act um uh unconstitutional
pattern practices or procedures uh with
respect to
voting that discriminate against the
race this doesn't
does require us to bring individual
cases
uh that is a much more time-consuming
and more expensive process
in fact what it does is it reverses the
burden of proof it was
normal during the vast bulk of my
lifetime that
if a jurisdiction wanted to change their
voting laws
it was a jurisdiction that was listed as
among those
having traditionally and historically uh
violated the constitution for voting
rights
the jurisdiction like that wanted to
change its voting laws
you know uh to to make people guess how
many jelly beans are
in the jar or or two to an
sweeping courages of voting roles things
like that
they had to get pre-clearance they had
to get permission from the attorney
general
and so the attorney general was in
control of that
now it's all flipped on its head the
attorney general has to file a lawsuit
and carry the burden of proof which
could involve
months and months and even years of
litigation
to invalidate you know a jim crow
kind of a voting law change like that am
i correct attorney general
you're muted again sir
am i mute now i can hear you okay thank
you
um uh yeah
i'm sorry i'm just uh get back to the
question you are correct that
the burden of proof is now on um the
justice department
to prove in each individual case a
violation of the voting rights center
well what we're here to talk about are
resources
for for your department of justice what
does that mean
if if we have any hope of preserving
voting rights
in the parts of this country that
historically discriminated against
african americans and others on the
basis of race
for voting rights if we're if we have
any hope of combating these changes
you know that that are being enacted
with vigorously now in the united states
how much money is it going to cost the
american taxpayer because of that shelby
county decision
the right to vote is absolutely
fundamental it is the
cornerstone of the democracy the justice
department
uh is pledged as part of its original
purpose
uh and its establishment during
reconstruction to protect voting rights
uh the 1965 voting rights act gave us
additional authorities
one part of which was removed and as a
consequence of the shelby
county case we do now have to bring each
case
individually and uh you are correct that
is a very large
investment of resources and that's part
of the reason why we're asking for the
um uh uh 15.8 percent
increase uh in the budget for the supply
division
well i thank you for that and i yield
now to our
distinguished ranking member mr aderholt
for five minutes of questions
okay thank you mr chairman oh
attorney general um my first question uh
would involve the immigration courts uh
advocates uh have
claimed that uh 89 percent
of all asylum applicants attended their
final court hearing to receive a
decision
uh on their application however this
claim is misleading because the doj's
own stats demonstrate that 38
of individuals whose cases begin with a
credible
fear never even bother to file an asylum
asylum application despite
claiming a fear of returning to their
home country
hence they are not even being counted
among the
pool of asylum applicants based on this
information
do you agree that this uh stats like the
uh doubtful 89 percent statistic i
mentioned
don't tell the whole story of the
immigration enforcement crisis that's
currently going on in this country
uh congressman i'm not familiar with
these specific
uh statistics uh nor nor the rebuttals
of the specifics that you're present
that you presented but i will certainly
ask
my team and the people who don't know
those statistics
uh to get back to your staff on that
okay that would be
really helpful if you could do that and
um
could you tell us what specific measures
that you have
implemented or maybe that you plan to
implement
to enforce the immigration laws and
protect the current rule of law
yes so there are for for the department
of justice
um uh there are a number of uh
issues uh i i'll make clear of course
that
the border patrol and the customs uh
and ice are all in the department of
homeland security and so they have the
primary responsibility
at the border we have a large number of
u.s attorneys at the border
who prosecute the cases that are brought
to them
by the department of homeland security
agents and so we part of our budget
request is for money for that
then we do um manage the immigration
courts the immigration judges that's our
executive office of immigration
uh review um that's the principal um
amount of the increase in money that
we're asking for in this area an
increase of 21
that's because we had uh at the time
the new administration took office over
a million
uh cases backlogged in that system and
a need new additional uh immigration
judges so part of this increase
is to add a hundred immigration judges
plus the teams of support
and technology that are necessary to
accelerate
uh the hearings in those cases
okay oh as as
is noted the immigration court backlog
stands over 1.3 million cases i
i think that you uh of that you have
noted that
in in 25 hearing locations
understand that an individual will wait
over three years for adjudication
and in three locations they'll wait over
four years
the previous administration implemented
a a case-based performance metrics
as a basis for evaluating immigration
court judicial resources
are those performance metrics still
being utilized under your administration
can you hear me yes my uh
my understanding is that the executive
offices of immigration review
is reviewing the nature of those metrics
trying to figure
out ways of accelerating performance
uh of course any system requires some
set of metrics
uh precisely which metrics are reviewed
uh on a regular routine basis
and we're going to be doing that to
ensure that we both
provide due process for the people
coming through the system
but also efficiency for the system
itself
oh effects is the pending caseload
having due process and do you have any
concern
about that issue at all
i'm i'm very concerned about the uh
backlog i think it
it obviously uh
not working for the people who are in
the system and not working for
the government with respect to value
evaluating those people those people
we have cut ij hiring uh times ij
immigration judges
uh from two plus years now to
approximately uh six months so
we expect to be able to get a lot more
immigration judges in
than so far we have been able to hire
and then we're asking for an additional
100
as well that should of course cut the
backlog
okay but due process is something you
were concerned about this year
yeah yes of course the longer people
are uh um are waiting uh uh and the
bigger the workload and the
faster uh judges have to decide uh the
less
uh due process is provided so we're
concerned to get the right balance
thank you thank you mr chairman thank
you mr aderhold
at this time the chair recognizes
representative grace ming for five
minutes of questions
thank you mr chairman uh congratulations
again
uh mr attorney general garland um
i wanted to applaud your march 30th
memorandum
which directs a 30-day review and
commitment to a whole of agency approach
to addressing hate-based violence and
incidents
against the asian pacific american
community
i appreciate so much your leadership and
shows the community
that their concerns are our government's
concerns
as you know may is asian pacific
american heritage month
and i believe this month's celebration
should be a clarion
call for the community and our nation
to shout that anti-asian hate is
unequivocally wrong
can you share with this subcommittee
what
the findings and recommendations
are and what additional resources do you
need to ensure
the change you envision will succeed
and part two of this question is
while your memo discusses the need for
better resources
to combat hate crimes you also state
correctly that communities will need
additional tools to heal
after hateful incidents occur there's a
great role for doj's community
ser relations service to play in lane
affect by hate crimes and violence
including those
who are the ones who commit the acts
some communities are distrustful of law
enforcement
and attorneys offices but may be more
receptive
to someone from crs
for solutions that bring restorative
justice
and peace to their community so i wanted
to ask from your perspective
is crs scalable um
and how can we work if
increasing funds that to work to ensure
that crs
will engage with communities on the
ground
and separately how can doj help
local community groups seek help outside
of the criminal justice
system developing alternatives to
carceral punishment for those convicted
of hate crimes
uh well you hit on a question that's uh
i i only recently realized uh was
extremely important not the hate crimes
issue but the community relations
service one so
um i'm very familiar with the service
having been quite important
uh the last time i was at the justice
department and doing the kind of work
you're talking about
in developing better relationships
between
communities uh victims and police
so one of the first things i did when we
were all concerned about
um what might be happening in
minneapolis
uh was to call and ask that members of
the community relations service
to assess how many there were there and
how many more could be brought
sadly i learned we only had about 26 or
27
total members of the community relations
service at this point
um that service has i would say badly
withered over the years
um over quite a number of years and so
an important part of our
request for a budget increase for the
civil rights division
is to increase hiring uh for the
community relations service
uh um so i think it's a very good uh
point you
raise and i'm not sure that many people
understand what good work the community
relations service
can do um with respect to the hate
crimes
issue um a significant part also of the
money
increase for civil rights division will
go to hate crime and prosecutions
um that the division does uh prosecute
those
um and uh with the additional money
we'll be able to look into that
uh further um you're also right
uh that prosecution isn't the only
solution here
and so we have grant programs under the
office of justice programs
hoping to move in that direction
you ask for non-incarceral resolutions
and so part of that
is what's called restorative justice a
chance for
uh victims uh and victimizers um
uh to work get together in a certain way
uh
to both reduce uh recidivism and to
reduce the pain felt by the victim so
there are a number of
it's a pretty broad set of programs that
we have available in this area
thank you so much i really look forward
to working with you on this issue
thank you i yield back
thank you representative ming at this
time the chair recognizes mr palazzo for
five minutes of questions
thank you mr chairman and uh attorney
general garland thank you for being
here today um i would like to briefly
address
the crisis that we have on our southern
border
it seems to be somewhat of a
manufactured crisis
but it is a crisis it is a huge
challenge
we basically have an invasion taking
place in our southern border
um and listen i know we got to handle
this in a humanitarian way and i'm all
for that but we're also a nation of law
and order
and without law and order we're creating
chaos
uh my biggest concern is the the
the flow of people not not those who are
coming through
uh the points of entry but it's the ones
that are
taking advantage of this crisis and it's
the human trafficking it's the drug
smuggling it's the bringing in of
foreign nationals
some who have been apprehended that we
know are on the terror watch list so can
you address
um what is the department of justice
seeing
at the border are there foreign actors
coming across
that are could be dangerous i mean what
are we doing
because we all respect you know the fbi
and our law enforcement communities
and officers and i just feel like that
we're just adding
um a huge burden
upon them but more so upon our local law
enforcement officers who are going to
have to
be basically dealing with this the
criminal activity that's coming across
and the hard narcotics in their
backyards can you
quickly address what the department of
justice is doing
and how are you advising the
administration to get this under control
okay i the issue of uh
major narcotics traffickers um sending
um
on narcotics across the border is a a
vital concern
to us particularly
now the transition to uh the synthetic
opioids
to the fentanyl um analogs
uh the precursors of these are
coming in some part from china moving
into mexico then moving across the
border
um we have put a lot of effort into um
interdiction um and into enforcement on
this we're spending
2.2 billion dollars in the current fy 21
budget across doj for immigration
southwest border enforcement
this uh funds our dea agents and as i
mentioned in a previous question our
prosecutors in in the southwest border
one of the first
uh things i did internationally as
attorney general was to speak to the
attorney general of mexico
uh to to seek and confirm his
cooperation
with respect to fighting a transnational
narcotics organizations
and he pledged his support to this as
well
so this is a serious problem and we are
seized with it
well one one thing's for sure the
transnational criminal organizations are
making a fortune
off the crisis at the border um and and
the the
the flow of drugs and if you just look
at what the coast guard's
pulling off the oceans before it makes
its way into america
and we're talking about hundreds of
millions of
tons of cocaine over the past several
years and
it's going to be a huge crisis i mean we
already have
you know so many issues to face in our
country
real quick can you address what are we
doing to counter
china especially in their theft of
international
or intellectual property we know
we know they they love to steal our
technology
and it's actually allowed them to close
the technological gap
uh to actually exceed us in some areas
which is a
national security crisis as well but
it's also just the theft of
you know trillions of dollars of our
resources paid
for either private or public
institutions here in america
obviously it's unfair they don't see it
that way
they they see it as all being you know
fair game uh to steal other countries uh
you know in intellectual property uh
what what's what's the doj doing to to
counter that
and are y'all um prosecuting uh
individuals engaged in the theft of our
international property within the last
month or so the intelligence community
has identified
china as a threat and precisely the
regard that you mentioned with respect
to uh espionage with respect to
theft of mutual property so um
you know the fbi um is working very hard
on
these issues there's also obviously an
important cyber crime
and cyber hacking element of this and uh
so a lot of money and the new resources
are being put into um protecting against
uh that hacking and uh then prosecuting
uh
where we're unsuccessful in protection
and then plugging the holes
well thank you sir um i appreciate your
time and
yield back mr chairman thank you mr
palazzo
at this time the chair recognizes mr
case of hawaii
for five minutes of questions
thank you attorney general garland first
of all i want to um
as a representative from hawaii with the
highest percentage of asia-pacific
americans in the entire country i want
to fully associate myself with
with uh my colleague ms ming's remarks
as to hate crimes
um as well as to endorse your efforts uh
to take a
a polo government approach uh that
that's critical
for us to get to the bottom bottom of
this and do whatever we can
uh in that regard so i appreciate your
effort on that front um
a second asked mr palazzo's comments
about
china the department the the department
of justice does have the china
initiative underway
which i believe is appropriate under the
circumstances i don't think any
any of us should be under any illusions
as to what china um
is up to here however uh there have
been many concerns across our country
especially in our chinese american
community as to
really profiling of of chinese americans
in connection with
reviews of china's interference and and
theft of our intellectual property et
cetera
particularly in our institutions of
higher learning so i would simply
relay a caution to you that
please be very attentive to those
concerns and take them seriously the
intelligence community has done that
and um within your own organization i
hope you will as well
let me cover a um an issue which is um
not specific to hawaii but
but uh but impacts us in particular and
that is
um that our in our federal district
court system our district of hawaii has
been without
a residential re-entry center for
almost two years now we had a
residential re-entry center or halfway
house if you want to refer to it as
that for 29 years until 2019
when the situation changed and we have
been struggling
uh with the doj and the bureau of
prisons in particular to get one
up and running again and of course you
know from your own experience that the
consequence of the absence of a
residential reentry center
uh not only prevents a reintegration of
federal inmates into their community but
in the case of
the district of hawaii i think this is
true beyond the district of hawaii
um the courts uh utilize that as an
alternative to incarceration for two
distinct populations
uh pre-trial uh release uh and those on
super
supervised released or so-called public
law placement
when you dig down to the bottom of this
issue it seems to be a question
it seems to be a question of unrealistic
expectations being placed on the
on the solicitation process and and the
bid process we are in a
unique situation here in hawaii and
essentially the solicitations are ruling
out any effective
bids on this and that that's uh that's
just not acceptable um we cannot send
our
you know prisoners and and uh um former
inmates you know to
to to the continental united states for
these purposes we shouldn't have to do
that
uh the discussion has been uh the
alternative of
day release which is not going to do the
trick and so i would simply ask for your
own uh personal
uh review and attention to this issue to
see whether we can't punch through this
and
and uh and get that solution in place as
soon as possible
may i marry may i respectfully request
that
uh yes of course uh residential re-entry
is uh critical uh to uh the first step
back and the second chance act uh
approaches which were passed by congress
they are the way
uh both to reduce our prison population
um and also to
prevent recidivism and to
make it easier for people to reintegrate
into the community
and become good citizens within the
community
so they are quite essential in that
regard um
i don't know the specifics with respect
to
the entry program and why although i do
understand that there's a new
solicitation being worked on
and i will ask my members of the team uh
to work out work this up and then
uh talk to your staff about it directly
thank you very much my remaining time
let me just
um follow up on mr palazzo's comments on
immigration and i won't have it
i won't have time for you to respond but
i leave this with you
um in in reviewing immigration and
especially a recent trip to the border
it
it it became crystal clear to me that
that that the burden on our immigration
judges
is in fact very very acute and is is
essentially incentivizing as mr palazzo
said
uh the cartels uh to to manipulate
weaknesses in our system
uh to basically enhance human
trafficking and their profits and the
critical weakness here is is a lack of
adjudication on a timely manner
of immigration related issues and so my
question to you
um and we can take this up after the
fact is is your request
itself sufficient uh to to handle what
you view as
as as a as a um correctly as
a as a huge uh problem um is that going
to do the job in terms of
re-incentivizing that and
i'm afraid i'm going to have to leave
leave you with that
hanging question and hopefully take it
up with you in some other way but it's a
rhetorical question is that enough
thank you mr chair thank you mr case and
we'll allow the witness to answer
uh take take 30 seconds and and tell us
what you can
in that space of time attorney general
so um can you hear me yes
yes yes so um we we have
uh asked for a substantial increase for
immigration judges and
uh equally important for the whole team
that supports uh
uh immigration judges um this will be
extremely helpful
for us at this point and this is the
mall
that we need right now
thank you at this time the chair
recognizes
congressman ben klein for five minutes
of questions
thank you chairman cartwright i
appreciate you and ranking member
aderholt for holding today's hearing
ensuring that our justice system is
operating effectively and efficiently in
accordance with the law is essential and
i appreciate
the attorney general uh his appearance
before us today to discuss the
department's funding request
i'll go out of order in my questions
briefly just to address the
burden on immigration judges i would
posit that it is a direct result of this
administration's changes in policies and
uh put in place a uh a catch and release
program repealing of
uh remain across the border while their
asylum claims are being heard
uh the numerous policy changes that have
incentivized
uh individuals to make this journey with
small children
and and claim asylum when uh for no
other reason other than they are
trying to escape poverty now that is a
reason to explore uh legal immigration
process and reforms but i would argue
that uh it is not cause for
asylum and i would argue that uh
before we grant a significant increase
in funding for immigration judges we
need to see some recognition by this
administration that it is first indeed a
crisis
and secondly that they are taking steps
to
address this crisis by restoring some
order to the border and some
uh structure to enforcing our border
um i want to ask the attorney general
in the past gao has estimated that the
department has not collected most of
the outstanding criminal debt uh both
fines and restitution
due to among other factors the nature of
the debt and a lack of coordination
between relevant doj components
my last report was that it was it was
under a five percent collection rate uh
that is
abhorrent at the end of fiscal year 2016
doj had identified 10
billion dollars of outstanding
collectible restitution
debt so as you come asking for an
increase in budgeting
is collecting this debt a priority for
the department at all
and is doj adequately measuring its
criminal debt collection performance
against any established goals
well certainly bringing in the money
that is uh owed
is very important to the department uh
this
problem of debt collection has been a
problem for
since the last time i was in the justice
department
and i certainly will uh draw my
attention to this again of course the
restitution issue
doesn't go to the government the
restitution goes to the victims
but i will i will certainly look at this
question the more money we can bring in
from people who owe
us money the less money uh we would need
from you uh although again i don't
believe the debt goes directly to the
justice department but to the treasury
as is appropriate i appreciate that
shifting over to another topic last year
we saw an unprecedented and an
overwhelming number of firearms sales
and with those sales and unprecedented
increase in
checks run through the national instant
criminal background check system in fact
the one year increase from 2019 to 2020
alone was nearly 40 percent in your
opinion does nics have the necessary
resources to handle what i'd imagine
is continued strain on the system and
can you provide the committee with the
latest stats
on the percentage of background checks
that fall into rather than proceed or
denied status
delayed status and the percentage of
those checks that are then resolved
within three business days
10 30 and 88 business days when they're
purged from the system
well um congressman you're absolutely
right that the more sales there are the
more pressure there is on
nics to do the background checks
obviously absolutely right
uh we have in fy 21 we received 168
million for expanding nick's capacity
and to address the workload increases
for fbi and atf
so we have resources that we're now
being able to put into this
uh problem um
i don't know the statistics um i know
the issue that you're talking about i
don't know the statistics on
how long a delay there is and whether
it's satisfied within
the three-day proceed um window
if you could give those to us i'd
appreciate that of course somebody would
do that
i'm just asked one more question that
current law requires a prospective buyer
of a firearm to provide a
photo id to exercise this core
constitutional right uh would you argue
that that is a reasonable requirement
i i i i would but i don't know what the
requirements are
again this is uh slightly beyond my area
of expertise and
i'd have to look into what the
requirements are
well 26a on the form requires a valid
government photo id
so that's the answer and you and you
would argue that that is a responsible
requirement i would would you also argue
that to exercise
your constitutional right to vote
requiring a photo id government-issued
photo id would also be a reasonable
requirement
i'm sorry you're muted sir
i'm sorry i think i may be being muted
by the committee every subcommittee
every time
a member speaks but we're doing the best
we can there's i appreciate that i'm
sorry
would you consider that yeah so so the
um question on voter id is what kind of
disparate impact
it has on um on voters of
different races colors uh and language
groups
and whether it violates the constitution
by having a disparate impact
on people's ability to vote supreme
court has held
that voter id as a concept is
constitutional
and the issue is what in any individual
cases the records show
about whether it deprives certain groups
protected by the
14th amendment right to vote
that's the question it's not a question
of whether voter id is sensible or not
sensible it's a question of
how it impacts and what the cost of that
impact is
but you don't ask if you don't ask that
question for a second amendment right so
when purchasing the firearm
okay thank you mr chairman all right
at this time the chair recognizes uh
congresswoman brenda lawrence for five
minutes of questions
hello everyone thank you so much and
congratulations
attorney general um i wanted
to um ask a question about
mental health and law enforcement the
biden administration skinny budget
includes an incentive to partner mental
health
providers with law enforcement across
the country which i believe is
incredibly
important as we look toward ensuring
that community policing and meeting the
needs of all of our residents
will the department be taking any
efforts to prioritize
grant applicants who attend to use
funds to expand or create partnerships
between mental health providers and law
enforcement
i think the answer in general for that
is yes
um we uh do believe that taking the
burden
off of law enforcement particularly with
some with respect to some of these very
high risk uh contacts with
uh people who have um
mental disability or who are in crisis
for any other reason
and to bring along or to substitute
social workers and mental health care
professionals
is a good way to reduce uh risk uh
for the officer and for the um
for the person who's involved so there's
a 271 million dollars in
our ojp increase request the office of
justice programs to
performing court processes and this
also includes uh separately
the question of having mental health
courts and drug courts
which is another related issue to the
one you're asking about
thank you so much i want to talk to you
a little bit about the civil rights
division for example after years of
arguing that a
texas voter id law intentionally
discriminated against minorities the
previous administration justice
department
abandoned that position today states
across the country
including my home state of michigan are
attempted to
pass restrictive measures that will
clearly make it harder
for americans to vote additionally even
a number of hate crimes across
the country spiked and federal
prosecutors or hate crimes have come
close to keeping pace
after can you tell me can you explain
how the civil rights division
will once again return to its mission
to oppose civil and constitutional
rights
for all americans the
justice department as i uh mentioned uh
is uh was founded uh with the principal
original purpose of protecting the
rights of
african americans during reconstruction
um
their rights particularly with respect
to voting
but also with respect to protection uh
against
uh uh domestic violent extremists
and uh the first uh incarnation of the
ku klux klan
that was the original purpose of the
department reinvigorated
when the civil rights division wasn't
created by one of the civil rights acts
um
we are carrying that forward now by
requesting a
18.6 increase in our budget for civil
rights
enforcement uh over last year uh
a portion of that money will go into uh
the voting rights issues about uh which
you were just speaking
and a portion of that money will also go
into
protection against enforcement
of hate crimes statutes
which congress has provided us
uh miss lawrence you are muted i think
the mint two things are really important
to me the mental health piece
when we look at justice and policing
and we see so many people who are
mentally ill and we see police officers
who are not equipped to respond to a
person having a psychotic
episode versus a criminal in addition to
that
if if you truly believe in something it
will be funded
and it will be a department under your
leadership
that will actively uphold their
responsibility when it comes to civil
rights so i look forward to your
leadership
thank you so much and um we have a lot
of work to do
in your department thank you so much and
i yield back
thank you congresswoman lawrence uh at
this time the chair recognizes
mr garcia for five minutes of questions
thank you mr chairman uh attorney
general thank you uh congratulations on
the appointment
uh and thank you for your service to to
our beautiful nation
uh and the uh the the monumental mission
you have in front of
you here uh i'm from uh california
northern l.a
county uh we are a state where uh we
have a legal cannabis
industry uh but we're also a state and
especially in my district in the deserts
uh above
los angeles where we're seeing a massive
influx
of an illegal uh marijuana
industry um and and i think it's being
understated at local levels at state
levels
and and certainly not appreciated at the
federal level
i i've been able to take a tour with the
local law enforcement agencies to see it
from the air
and i can tell you firsthand that if you
remember the first time you went flying
over a small neighborhood
your reaction was probably wow i can't
believe there's
there's this many pools in our
neighborhoods um
i have the same i had the same reaction
when i toured our antelope valley area
with regards to these illegal
uh pot operations there are literally
hundreds if not
thousands of these uh greenhouses being
uh propped up in our in our deserts
uh in areas where where frankly uh
vegetation should not be growing it's
difficult to
to farm out here what's happening is we
have folks who are
operating illegally on a black market
who
are stealing natural resources they're
stealing water
in many cases the folks working these
these illegal pot
operations or indentured servants
illegally
here trying to make ends meet and being
taken advantage
we have folks being local citizens being
intimidated by
by some of these transnational criminal
organizations that are running these
illegal marijuana operations
uh the the magnitude of this problem is
staggering
and i and i know that the federal
government i know that doj
under dea has pots of money that uh that
do go towards uh eradicating these
illegal marijuana operations um
but it but it is that a it is at a
magnitude like i said that's beyond
comprehension i think and i and i
and i really do believe it's worth the
doj's attention
not only at the federal level but but
also in support of the local
law enforcement agencies my question is
is what in your opinion can be done from
a federal level
to to help prosecute folks who are
growing uh marijuana illegally
there's a series of charges that have
been deemed really misdemeanors the
the distribution the sale the growing of
marijuana in california is treated as
misdemeanors but the stealing of natural
resources in some cases the spotting
on on land uh the intimidation
against local residents for reporting
recorded
um is is is is is rising to the level of
uh
a felony behavior and frankly it's a
it's it is a true
security uh issue at the local level
uh but also national security uh what
what can we do at the federal level
under your administration
administration and and your leadership
to help us
uh eradicate the illegal marijuana
problem
well um i'm not precisely familiar with
the specifics obviously
that you were able to see through your
aerial flights
but the department's view on marijuana
use
is that that enforcement
against use is not a good use of our
of our resources i understand that's not
what you're talking about
you're really talking about uh growing
and manufacturing at a large scale
um we are
probably not a good use of our resources
where it is regulated
by the state uh um
and again i take it that that's not what
you're asking about
so right to the extent you're asking for
example about
transnational operations of large
amounts coming from mexico
or of transnational operators who are
coming into the united states to do the
growing these are
certainly within our jurisdiction and
within our scope of concern well
thank you attorney general i would i
would love to to host you out here just
to
to get you and your your uh respective
points of contact a first row view of
what's going on out here it is
staggering
uh the local law enforcement agencies
get about uh
19 000 per year from the federal
government
uh for overtime to help uh fight this uh
they hit that cap that nineteen thousand
dollar limit uh usually in june or july
of each year and it's frankly not enough
and like i said this we've had seven
dead bodies show up
at these illegal grows here in southern
california just in the last few months
uh would really appreciate uh hosting
you out here
and getting not only the dea but also
atf and fbi
representatives to see firsthand what
we're seeing on the ground here and i
yield back mr chairman
thank you mr garcia at this time the
chair recognizes mr
trone of maryland for five minutes of
questions
uh thank you and um sec attorney general
garland it's great to be here with you
today
uh for the last decade or so my office
has been in bethesda
uh so we're neighbors and it's awesome
to have someone of your
qualifications uh in this job
i want to start off today about
pre-trial
and jail incarceration rates
even short stays pre-trial detention is
associated with harmful outcomes
costing people their jobs their homes
lose custody of their kids
this practice is also leads to an
increased likelihood
of being convicted receiving a harsher
sentence
and future involvement in the criminal
justice system
uh the pre-trial detention rates in the
federal system
are at a record level
of 75 individuals detain pre-trial
disproportionately this falls on people
of color
uh federal prosecutors have requested
from 56 percent
in 1997 now up to 77
even though the data shows 99
of those released return to jail to
court
so mr garland could you speak uh to
doj's
current uh pre-trial retention policies
and your views uh on pre-trial detention
uh well uh congressman i i quite agree
with the concerns you express
i do think that unnecessary pre-trial
detention does make it harder for
somebody
to build a case uh to defend themselves
which is point one and point two uh
often means they lose their job
uh which uh even if they are
then adjudicated as not guilty uh
damages
uh their ability to make a livelihood so
there's no question about that
i served when i was the chief judge of
the us code of appeals for the dc
circuit on the executive
committee of the pre-trial services
agency for the district of columbia
that's a statutory appointment
that agency has a nation-leading
reputation for analyzing uh pre-trial
detainees and
making recommendations to judges um
about which ones need to be detained
which ones don't and what kind of more
minimal
conditions can be required so um because
they have a very good
method of figuring out who might
recidivate while on release
uh or after release and i i know that
the judges of both the federal court and
the
spirit court are happy with the results
of that
so one thing might be uh to help model
that program
in other districts um the federal law
uh commits pretrial detention only if
there's no
combination of other kinds of conditions
that will ensure
the return of the um of
of the person who's been arrested
uh and or and secure the safety of the
community that's the underlying test
there are provisions that provide a
presumption of detention
when the sentence faced is extremely
high
or when the crime itself is extremely
dangerous but even in those
circumstances it's
only a presumption
according to the vera senator justice
after the enactment of war crime bill
you spent 127 million a year
on pre-trial detention today's dollars
today that's over two billion dollars
yet our prison population
has been reduced uh significantly from
where it was three decades ago
does this seem like somewhat of an
outsized increase
uh to you uh given these crime rates are
lower
you know i honestly don't know i i don't
i don't know the viral statistics i
don't
whether the reference is to federal
pre-trial detention
or not as you can imagine um
we are not charging people with
low-level crimes
in order to prioritize our resources
and uh frankly to be complete to be fair
and just
we are looking for only
the area street crime violent
offenders uh big time offenders
so it may be that our detention
statistics are higher than you might
guess for example
if what we're looking at is what a local
prosecutor
uh brings in but i to be honest i simply
don't know
uh the statistics that you're citing uh
thank you that's the federal number the
quickly the president's skinny budget
outline 1.5 billion
dollars an increase over 500 million for
grants to support the reform
of state and local criminal justice
systems
including federal funding to support
diversions
and alternative court programs right can
you expand
on how the funding could be used
allocated to safely
reduce rates of pre-child attention
well that's that's part of the important
role that these
that these alternative programs provide
the drug courts the mental health courts
often allow
people released on personal recognizance
at least altogether
pending various kinds of agreements to
monitoring
and substance abuse
taking substance abuse programs that
sort of thing and as you said there's a
271 million dollars in the ojp
office of justice programs proposal
which can be given for
those kinds of programs
i yield back thank you mr trone
general garland and members of our
subcommittee we will now take a 10
minute recess
and we will resume for our second round
of questioning
at 11 25 a.m we're in recess
you